okay so thank you all for coming I
apologize about the delay I'm shocked
that we actually found each other it was
a I was like are you near a building and
you said yeah I'm outside near a
building and then we found each other
like two ships in the night
my name is Seth manukan I'm the director
of the communications forum we have
three events a semester every semester
we have a mailing list sign up okay
they're a mailing list sign up we'll go
get passed around if you sign up we you
you will only get six possibly eight
emails a year from us telling you when
those events are so if you're interested
in this type of programming and would
like to come please sign up so we can
keep you informed this event is also
being filmed and it will be archived
later on so if you did not get enough of
it tonight you can watch it again or if
you know someone who's interested and
could not make it you can tell them
it'll probably up in a couple days as
will a summary of the event our next
communication forum event is March 14th
it is actually a new type of thing for
us it's the stand-up comedian Cameron
Esposito who will is phenomenal if you
don't know her you should check her out
she will be doing a stand-up set and
then QA so please come join us at that
and I think that's it for announcements
now let me introduce our speakers
cynthia graver is an award-winning radio
producer and journalist whose work
appears in Slate the Boston Globe PR
i--'s the world Scientific American and
what did we but what did we work on what
was the but now defunct publication yeah
right right yes you want an award for it
I know yep which you deserve all the
credit for not me it's true I was not in
2014 she co-founded gastropod
is a phenomenal podcast about food and
science in history it has won a regional
Edward R Murrow award an International
Association of culinary professionals
award and it was named Boston's best
podcast by the improper Bostonian synthy
was also a night journalism fellow at
MIT a night science journalism fellow in
2012 and she current currently teaches
the podcasting and radio journalism
segment for MIT graduate program and
science writing which I also direct and
if you're interested in that you should
get in touch with me as well and it says
here she's fluent in four languages
which is three and a half more than me
Spanish Hebrew French and English really
I named it I Bearcats @efreeti Letson is
came here all the way from California
which we hugely appreciate is a Peabody
and Emmy award-winning radio host
performance artist and playwright he
currently hosts reveal which is a public
radio show and podcast created by the
Center for Investigative Reporting and
prx it's out its fourth season okay it's
now in its multiple seasons it has
received an enormous amount of acclaim
around the country and around the world
for its in-depth investigative
journalism on issues including an inmate
abuse white nationalism immigrant
detention camps and lots of other cheery
topics the Atlantic says the experience
of each episode is akin to a spoonful of
sugar even when it's telling a story
about Richard Spencer's cotton farms or
a man's final days as a heroin addict
before reveal out spent years on the
road telling the story of America one
community at a time as the host of the
public radio show state of the reunion
and he also hosts co-hosts a culture
podcast saying you referred to as like
your own personal mixtape so right ear
thang he is a former flight attendant
and writer for DC Comics I feel like
both of those are equally impressive and
after so the way this will work they'll
have a conversation for probably roughly
an hour after that we'll do an audience
Q&A
we can either repeat the questions or
hand you a mic but if you're comfortable
please let us know your name so if there
are people watching we can at least say
vaguely who you are
alright thank you very much and thank
you too okay
well mmm this is very exciting it's fun
to be here with all of you talking about
podcasting is one of my favorite things
in the absolute world as some of you
know and also I am a big fan of Al's
work and so I thought that maybe we'd do
a little bit more in-depth introductions
of ourself and then have questions for
you and we'll keep chatting so why don't
you talk a little bit how you got into
state of the reunion you know tell us a
little bit well he talked a little bit
about reveal but not so much about our
thing which is really interesting and
and I wanted you know how you got into
audio and how you kicked off your own
podcast sure I I I used to think that
saying that like I got into radios kind
of an Orthodox past but path but I think
that everybody kind of takes in an
Orthodox past two paths to podcasting I
I guess around 2007 I was watching
American Idol with my daughter
and I never watched American Idol but I
was just hanging out with her and
afterwards I wanted to know if the girl
that I liked won so a couple days later
I googled American Idol and the first
thing that popped up was NPR's American
Idol and I thought it was a folk singing
competition but I like folk music so
whatever like I clicked on it and they
were looking it was this competition by
prx which is based here in Boston by prx
and the center of the not the center but
the Corporation for Public Broadcasting
they were looking for new hosts new
shows new ideas and because of my time
as a flight attendant well so when I was
a flight end I was doing like two
different things I was a flight
attendant but I was also a performing
artists spoken word artist so I was
doing a lot of poetry slams and so I
would fly to different cities
form and then I'd end up having to sleep
on somebody's floor couch right which is
not the traditional thing that flight
attendants do like usually go to a hotel
I came to Boston several time I think
the place that I was slamming at Boston
was the can tab yeah okay so that was so
long ago I mean this is like in 99 98
when I was doing it so anyway yeah so I
I because I had seen the country from
kind of the bottom up hanging out with
poets and an activists I had this idea
of what I thought America looked like
and felt that so much of the media
wasn't talking about it so I pitched
that idea the idea the pitch that
symptom was called state of the reunion
I just was I just spit balled it
actually it was like I want to do a
state of the reunion yes and I ended up
winning the contest they picked three
winners who was me Glen Washington I'm a
jock or Carter and yeah we I went on in
I Glen and I took really different paths
to make Radio Glen one and to get people
who didn't make radio before to come in
and do it and I had a sound that I was
trying to achieve and so I did it the
opposite way I went out and found a lot
of great audio producers who were kind
of young in their career but also had a
lot of potential and and everybody that
got hired would state of the reunion
really believed in what we were doing
it's a really different type of show in
the sense that like yeah like the number
one thing that you could always pick
with anybody in my and my crew at the
time was like passion for the idea a
passion for the idea that America is
such a rich and diverse place and we
don't talk about that enough in our in
our news in our storytelling especially
at the time and also like this is like
right around the time when Obama first
got in office so we were filled with
hope
yeah yeah so so yes that was state of
the union and how I got into it when I
first started doing State of the Union
we were primarily radio I remember I was
at a party and what happens to me at
parties when people find out what they
what I do they corner me and they told
me some either crazy story or something
crazy that I should be doing or bla bla
bla I remember this guy came up to me
he's like dude his name was Steve I
still couldn't see Steve in my head he
was like a big hippie with a long
ponytail and he was like dude podcasting
is the future and I was like come on
Steve you've had too much to drink
give me my iPod like what do I cast it
what is that I didn't I didn't even know
what he was talking about and Here I am
so Steve was 100 was right makes me feel
like so I also had a not quite as
unusual way to get into audio but I did
my masters here at BU and science
journalism long time ago I started in
1998 and I've been in Boston and they we
were supposed to tear so I hadn't been
an NPR listener you know I'd been living
in Israel and there was no kind of NPR
type storytelling on the radio there and
before that I was in college I was
traveling and I wasn't an NPR junkie at
the time you know my mom would put it on
and I go why are all those people
talking I want to listen to music now of
course I'm the one who always wants to
talking people on but um so when I was
in grad school we had to take a video
class and at the time there was no like
video for the web and I was like well I
don't want to do science reporting for
TV you know it's two seconds long and
you always have that b-roll of pills
falling off and to you know like that's
boring and there was a radio class and I
was like well I did theater my whole
life like I thought a resume was the
plays you had been in and you know when
I was seven and had my resume and took
it around to to auditions and I was like
I'm gonna take our radio class cuz I
really like microphones and then I was
hired I had an internship at living on
Earth which is an NPR show and
I was hired two weeks later and that was
almost 20 years ago
so that was my entrance to it but the
podcasting thing is really interesting
right I I worked at Loa and then I quit
and I ended up at a show that isn't
around anymore called world vision
report for about seven years and then I
had started podcasting was kind of
coming on and I I did some for years I
was podcasting for Scientific American
and then I would guest host for some
other science podcasts and I started
thinking I might be able to do my own
thing
you know like world vision report folded
I had a fellowship here at MIT and I
kept thinking like I'm ready to be my
own boss like I'm ready to come up with
my own idea my brilliant idea at the
time
not such a brilliant I mean it's not a
bad idea but it wasn't really where I
thought I could do the most but I was
like okay I'm gonna do a podcast about
women in science and I'm not gonna ask
them any of the stupid questions women
always get asked I'm not gonna ask them
how they do with childcare I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna ask them anything you
wouldn't ask a guy I'm just gonna find
out what they're passionate about and
like what's exciting about their work
and a friend of mine so my night year I
was hanging out with a friend of mine
really awesome journalist and she says
that's great and then you're gonna
become an expert in women in science and
I stopped and I said well that's
literally everything I can't become an
expert on women in science so what is
the like topic that I'm absolutely
obsessed with it's this intersection of
food science and history and so I
started doing some market research I'm
like okay no one's doing this there's
like cooking shows there might be some
like cooking with science shows but
there's nothing that was like marrying
my own obsessions in a radio world in
the podcasting world I had after my
night year met Nicki my co-host at
another fellowship with Michael Pollan
at UC Berkeley and she had a blog called
edible geography and this is about a
year after our fellowships this is 2014
and I saw on we'd become friends we
liked each other's work and I saw on
Twitter that she was having a really
crappy day and I was like so I had just
written up kind of my proposal I had
this idea that maybe I would like join
with a magazine and friends had said you
need a deadline you have to write a
proposal I did that I sent Niki an email
I said it seems like you're having a bad
day do you want do you want a
distraction I really want to get your
feedback you know
food and media I'm curious what you
think she said yes please give me a
distraction so I sent her my proposal
like two seconds later I get an email
back you need a co-host and I was like I
do need it goes and then it turned into
our baby and we launched it four months
later I love us he was like I want a job
I didn't know so Nicky had never done
audio before so I had to teach her
everything but I didn't she had a
full-time job that was not in writing
and she was doing a lot of writing on
the side
and that she wanted that to be her
full-time gig but that job that gave her
the time to write was ending so she
actually had time what she didn't know
is that one we were getting married and
two it was way more work than she ever
look she had no idea what she was
signing up for which is something I
think we're gonna talk about when we
talk about what it actually takes to
make something of quality but so talk
about so podcasting the dude with the
ponytail the hippie guy was right he's
totally right it's it's a big deal these
days so everything is totally different
from reveal which you hosted yeah and
it's beautifully produced and it's
really fascinating and really compelling
and how this is your kind of artistic
baby where did that come from yeah I
mean so what I've always been really
clear about with with all the work I do
is sort of like what's its place and
what does it need from me
right and so when I was doing state of
the reunion what state of the reunion
needed from me was visit vision and you
know hosting I worked with such amazing
journalists as long as I said vision
they came along and they found great
stories and we just made something
really great together but that was my
number one job with state of the reunion
just have a strong vision set for it
what we're gonna do and go out and make
it happen and remove obstacles from the
people that we're making it with me with
reveal my role in reveal is strictly as
the host - at times play the voice of
authority but also at times to have wide
open questions you know to sit in for
the for the audience and then also
because
investigative journalism to hold people
accountable in both of those roles in
both state of the reunion and in
revealed there's not a whole lot of room
for me to stretch out and be me and we
find little places in both shows where I
can do that a little bit but it's really
constraining and instead of like trying
to force me being me in places where
it's not really right where
journalistically I shouldn't be doing
that and also like we stated the reunion
for me it was so much about the
communities we were going to I wanted
them to have the spotlight and not me
but I'm a performer I'm a middle kid I'm
addicted to clap cocaine I need people
to clap for me and and so when I started
think thank you oh when I started I
started getting frustrated that revealed
that like I wasn't able to tell more
funny stories that I wasn't able to like
dive in and also like a reveal I don't
do a lot of production like every now
and then we'll do an interview and I'll
know exactly how I want that interview
cut and I'll just tell them like I'll
cut that but it's pretty rare so our
thing came out of this desire to like I
had something to say I wanted to play a
little bit and I also loved I love
cutting tape it's like one of my
favorite things in the world you know
and then like when you cut a story and
you score it just right like the thrill
of like all of you coming together is
such a rush so that's how like
everything came about it was just me
needing to stretch my artistic wings so
to speak and you and I have had a
different approach and it's gonna kind
of lead into where I want to go with
this discussion and so with gastropod
Nicky and I saw it as a business from
day one we knew eventually we wanted
this to be I mean we still want it to be
like you know a big media enterprise we
run our own media company right like
this is what gastropod is and and so we
said okay we're a startup and what do
startups do okay so we're gonna focus on
what our business plan is how we're
gonna make money we're not gonna pay
ourselves for a year because people who
do startups don't pay them
for a year often and we're gonna have
like this vision of how we want to
handle that and we you know we had our
logo designed and we built a website and
we figured out what stories we want to
do at the beginning and find things that
would be really compelling to people and
have some names people would recognize
on the show even before we had a name
for our show we were getting some pretty
well known folks in the business you
know Twitter handle Facebook page we
started to reach out to people we knew
in media to kind of generate excitement
and and really kind of build up a
following even before we launched and
this is back you know so we started kind
of talking about it in like May June we
launched in September and I was really
worried that you know maybe we'd only
have like 100 listeners who's gonna
listen to this one week and it already
within the first the first episode
immediately was like 8 to 10 thousand
like we were really fortunate that we
had great connections and we could kind
of figure out how to work that and then
and then because we had connections in
the media world from our own work we
were like hey you know check it out if
you want to and so people covered it in
Fast Company in National Geographic and
Boston Globe within a few months and we
also kind of we were thinking okay we're
gonna put out an episode every month and
we'll do a little bite-sized piece every
two weeks because we want to stay in
people's ears was you know kind of
strategy and then we quickly realized we
hated the bites cuz they weren't they
weren't fulfilling our artistic vision
for the show and so we very quickly were
like nope full episodes every two weeks
I mean talk about work creep it's like
constant work creep and so that's kind
of the theme of it but we are now paying
ourselves a full-time salary as a
journalistic like fully like really
produced highly produced podcast which
makes us kind of unicorns in that part
of the world but so you know when you
were thinking about launching the show
well you talked about your artistic
vision that this was you and your art
but did you plan a launch did you think
about your audience was what was that
about like four you know and this is
probably the worst advice to give
anybody that's going into podcasts like
the absolute worst advice which is like
well okay it's the worst advice to give
to anybody that
going into podcasting with the idea of
making money I have no desire to make
any money off of our thing I just really
want everything to pay for itself what
does that mean that means that like the
first season I got a grant from a local
philanthropist in Jacksonville Florida
who I'm really really good with she gave
me enough money to like make the first
season which meant that like I could pay
Willy I could pay bri-bri berge has been
my business manager since I did state of
the reunion I could pay rent at the
studio that I have that I own in Florida
so it did all that and that's really
like all I have to do I gave myself a
couple hundred dollars I think but on
the whole I didn't really make I mean
taxes ate that so um and then the second
season we did it with radio topia which
was amazing because radio topia did give
us a good little bit of money which
allowed me to be a lot more ambitious
and so like when i'm thinking about the
third season i am going to talk to
people about coming in and you know
funding it because I have really
ambitious plans for what I want to do in
the third season like really ambitious
plans yeah exactly so like that's why I
like I don't need a thing to let me make
me money and also like I do earthing
this is the number one golden rule that
I break with earthing is like like I
don't think about how often I need to
come out
I just come out when I'm when I'm ready
with reveal if we did that we would lose
like all of our numbers you know we
would we would not be in people's a year
it is not a good strategy because what
happens is that like every season I'm
like trying I'm helping people refined
us again but also I just do it for the
love of it and I would do it if nobody
listened to it like Willie and I would
geek out in our little Garage Band and
having this is not geeking out I mean
these are beautifully like this is this
is clearly theater right like I thought
of that geeking out that you guys are
doing this is oh yeah it's it's it's
planned although like I was talking to
Willie two days ago and I was like
dammit dude like every time we talk we
just need to record because we the way
we sound on the show is definitely the
way we talk to each other I believe and
I also think that the show has like
framed like now that we've done the show
the way we talk kind of follows that
right yeah it's like you know like you
talk to each other on the microphone
like this and suddenly it becomes you
talk to each other Mickey and I are on
the phone together four or five hours a
day right so yeah so you you you you
fall into those things but but yeah we I
had no game plan
neither financially nor how to get the
word out or anything all I really wanted
to do was to make something that I'd
really be proud of and so this can i I
just want to jump in because this leads
to something that was really funny to me
when we talked on the phone before this
which is gastropods my full-time again
we live and die by our numbers right
like funding agencies aren't interested
in us if we don't have an audience our
audience isn't going to support us if we
don't have enough of them to give us
money advertisers they care how many
listeners we have I check our listener
numbers multiple times a day so tell me
I haven't even looked at them for season
two like I have not there's like some
episode there's like we did
I love season two in a cause I felt like
season one like I was just figuring out
what what it was I was trying to say and
in season two like I knew exactly what I
wanted to say it and I crafted that
whole season with that thought process
in mind and so there's like some really
there's pieces in that I just loved so
much and I'm so curious like if anyone's
heard it but then on the flip side I'm
like whatever let's just keep making so
no I don't look on reveal though I don't
look at the numbers on reveal either but
everybody else does it's not my job to
look at the numbers but everybody else
is always sweating like oh my god we got
to think of this new thing to keep our
numbers going you know yeah and that's
what something I was gonna ask you
actually like how on reveal how D or
honor thing like how did you try it all
with our thing to like you know how you
found listeners a none reveal when you
talked about finding new listeners what
do you talk about what
strategy yeah so I mean with everything
like no I'm honestly I'm literally like
I'm just concentrating on the creative
side of things recently I applied her
thing for like some awards and I had to
think about like how I communicate what
we do which was I haven't really had to
do that before because I just didn't
worry about it just worried about like
creating this thing that that really
spoke to me so don't think about that
much with reveal we are constantly
thinking about like how we attract new
audiences we're getting ready to work on
a serial story it's um it's a story that
it's my story I found this story when I
was working for state of the reunion in
2012 and it's in the deep south and it's
a it's a murder mystery and everybody's
doing murder mysteries now and they like
kind of there's there's some things that
drive me crazy about murder mysteries
and so what I'm doing is like guiding
our serial away from all those things
that drive me crazy like one thing that
I hate being a southerner one thing that
I hate is how podcasts will come to the
South and they'll take a story away and
not quite understand the context totally
and then and not leave the community
with anything you know yes I'm talking
about s town so like what I'm trying to
do with what we're doing is is be
accountable to the community that we are
in but also think about how do I talk to
people in the community who don't listen
to podcast like most of the people in
the community that I'm looking at I mean
the lead characters the lead characters
passed on but the lead character sisters
my point of contact with the family and
her phone number changes like at least
every three months she still has a plan
where she runs out of minutes and data
usage right and that's like that's real
for her life she's not listening in the
podcast so how do I like tell the story
that's relevant to her to her
that's about her and let her reflect you
know in a way with media that she
actually can engage in and so we're
thinking about like
how to do that type of stuff because we
know like we know like that we'll get
what we singing to the choir is easy
like I know they're gonna come I'm
constantly trying to think about like
how I can bring more people into the
room one so then how do you so you
obviously you're on public radio
stations but in terms of the podcast
itself you have this big project you
want to get the word out more you want
to get new podcast listeners have you
guys talked about what you want to do
for that yeah so I mean first and
foremost like it's like if you really
want to go get new listeners you've got
to have like a really smart PR campaign
to like go out and get it which you know
and is another reason why I don't do it
with earthing cuz I have money to do our
QA but you but you really do I mean like
it's there's so many podcasts out there
now that if you don't figure out a way
to like make yourself stand out and get
attention and to get people writing
about you and talking about you then
you're you're you're at a loss already
right so you have to figure that out so
we're thinking about that - I think so
one of the ways that we're thinking
about the story that I'm pitching is
that a lot of the folks that we are
telling the story about are poor African
Americans in the deep south being that I
come from the deep south like I
understand the culture in a way and I
was and because this has to do with like
a young black man being killed by police
we're gonna be we're reaching out to
like a bunch of hip-hop artists in that
part of the world and telling them the
story and see if any of them want to
make you know a song to go on their
album that like we don't own at all it's
their song we'd give them like audio
bytes from the show and have them mix it
into the music like that kind of stuff
like thinking about like how to meet
people where they are and hopefully if
we meet people where they are then they
say well I want to know more about this
and they start listening to the stories
you know and so for us it's a like that
wording I think is is really something
we think about - is like finding
listeners where they are and obviously
for gastropod again like I'm obsessed
with our numbers the the there was a big
shake-up in Apple a year ago
and Apple changed how they do their
metrics and everybody lost about 40% of
what their podcast downloads were and
nobody really wants I'm telling you this
now nobody wants to talk about it like
no podcasts would admit how much they
lost from that but it was probably about
40% mostly across the board and we were
doing really well and then all of a
sudden were like yeah and then there's
some weird thing happening with our RSS
feed now that I think is also technical
that we were kind of inching back up and
that we've lost a bunch now to that I
don't think is just attrition I think
there's some other kind of shift going
on and you know so we we think about
this all the time and for us the biggest
way to find listeners has been to find
them where they are which is where a
podcast listeners listening to other
podcasts so for us trying to find
listeners is like well how do we get
cross-promotions how do we get gastropod
mentioned on other shows and we've
thrown every piece of spaghetti against
the wall and we keep on trying to make
more spaghetti and throw it against the
wall - and right now we're just like
reaching out to any show that might be a
good fit for a cross-promotion that
maybe would want to interview us about
something that we've covered that's kind
of quirky and weird that might fit in
with their topic I do have a
cross-promote coming up that's like an
audience that probably hasn't heard of
the show before but I meet people all
the time who's like you know we think
our audiences everyone like everybody
eats right but there are people who
naturally are like obsessed with these
topics and they'll say how have you been
around for four and a half years and
I've never heard of you so it's a really
you know articles for us
I mean maybe more so now because people
are more familiar with podcasts but the
only print article that made a
difference for us was when Wired named
us one of their favorite scripted
podcasts in their print magazine because
Wired listeners and this is a few years
ago but Wired listener wired readers our
podcast listeners absolutely yeah it's
totally hard and you got to think about
those crossovers and how you how you can
do yeah so you know as you said
podcasting is growing these days what do
you think about what's going on in the
state of podcast world I think we're you
know honestly I think we're in a bubble
and I think that bubble is gonna pop
really soon and I think that
you know I think we began to see the
decline of people organizations that
want to put money into podcasts like you
can see like and and I have plenty of
judgment over this like I think that
BuzzFeed when they killed like their
podcasting department is is a sign of it
but also I thought it was a good stuff
they killed some good stuff I thought it
was extremely short-sighted too I think
is extremely short-sighted but but but
yeah I mean like you can see like
there's all sorts of organizations I
think Penn Apple II did some stuff where
they cut a bunch of there's only like so
they're no longer a slate still has some
slate podcasts right panoply is now only
a marketing like an somehow a content
and advertising company so anything else
they were doing is gone yeah
so it's like I think in those moves you
can see the industry kind of contracting
a little bit I would like to quote you
because I think we're gonna do this I'm
gonna own it with you so I'm not
throwing you under the bus here when we
were on the phone you said that maybe
that means that some listen like there
are things that I would love to do that
I should not do me too
like I should I should not be an Olympic
swimmer I should not I would drowned I
should I should not go to MIT I would
not do well here I couldn't find the
damn building
totally normal
there just like it like no like I just
don't like math like it's nothing like
I'm clear about some things I can
appreciate it and I'm really happy to
support other people who do it because
you do it for me thank you
same thing with podcasting like now
everybody and their mom thinks everybody
and their celebrity best friend yeah
thinks that they can do a podcast and
they should and that they should do a
podcast and
I mean hey man go ahead do you think if
you think that that that you should but
I just think that yeah like the
contraction means that we're gonna lose
a lot of flimsy ass podcasts and I'm
happy about that
the sad part the thing that I'm not
happy about is that we lost some really
great podcast we did but so I so I have
a couple thoughts on that where I'm not
sure as much that there's a bubble I
think there's a bubble in the thought of
everybody wanting to do a podcast and
everybody thinking they can do a podcast
and everybody thinking it's easy to do a
podcast and as many of you out here know
cuz I've taught a bunch of you it's not
I mean you can learn like there's a
learning curve it's it's a skill you can
learn it it helps if you have a trained
ear for audio production and if you have
a good ear for it which obviously can be
learned too but it you know but there's
writing and sound and production values
and all of these things I think are
really important and I think what most
people don't realize is that it's
actually really hard work it takes a
long time to do it well it yeah it takes
a really long time I mean I cannot
listen to season 1 and season 2 of state
of the reunion because I sound horrible
I can't listen to my old I just like I
don't even know how they let me on the
air with that but like it took years for
me to like figure out exactly like where
my voice should be it took me a long
time to figure out that like right for
you how to write for the voice right how
to like and what it is like I think that
you know like I've learned how I know my
sweet spot I know like what I'm telling
a story like what exactly I'm working
for because I know I do that really well
but it took me a long time to figure
those those type of things out and so I
think yeah like people tend to think
that it's easy I think the the other
place that I think it's a bubble is that
there's a lot of production companies
that are making brandy comp branded
content now and I think that at all of
those places that are doing it they're
great people that work there I'm just
curious like how long that's gonna last
right cuz who's listening to it maybe
they're getting good numbers I don't
know um but but I just tend to think
that you know if you're branded content
you are basically telling and making
stories for a big brand company ie blah
blah blah all of that type of stuff and
they don't have the the most patience
when it comes to projects right so yeah
I just I wonder how long that's gonna be
I think that also like when when
podcasting really blew up with cereal
you know MailChimp was everywhere right
yeah but now you don't hear MailChimp
ads that much anymore and my
understanding is is that like and I'm
not picking on MailChimp I'm just saying
in general that like when it comes to
ads advertisers are beginning to pull
back a little bit because they're not
seeing the return on investment that
they were seeing before so I actually I
have a little bit different maybe
slightly different insight from the ad
company we work with also some slightly
different thoughts on the idea of a
bubble and you you would know this way
better than me because I don't so I
think that the research shows that it's
still a fairly small percentage of
Americans who listen to podcasting
regularly and it's growing and so
there's a still a huge potential
audience out there also podcasting only
captures a small percentage over the of
the overall audio marketing budget that
people are spending and so I think
there's room both huge room for growth
and I don't even think that the amount
that podcasting captures is commensurate
with the size that podcasting reaches
now what's going on now is that we
actually have pretty high CPMs which is
how much money we get for how many
thousand people listen to the show and
it's much better for online and frankly
the ads are a lot more effective people
tend not to fast-forward through ads we
try to make sure they don't fast-forward
through our ads we put little bits of
weird science and history and our ads to
make them interesting that aren't like
they might be about they're about a
topic related to the company they're
rarely about that specific company
because we're like we don't we know soon
if you can't do it now you're gonna be a
lot of fast for it their ads and we
don't want to but when Apple's data came
out last year I wouldn't even look at it
and I made Nicki
look because what they were also showing
was how what percentage of people listen
all the way to the end of the show after
they start it and I was like I can't
look I can't look just tell me what it
says and ours was really high of people
who listened all the way through to the
end it was like I don't know 80 90
percent most of the time which was great
and most of them it was clear didn't
drop out during the ads so like I think
there's still a lot of room for growth
in the industry I am hoping though that
it not that it shakes out in a bad way
like what what happened with BuzzFeed I
mean my I don't know cuz I don't work
there but I feel like maybe people don't
realize how much of a financial and time
investment podcasting is and so they
don't realize how much they're actually
gonna have to pay people to do it well
yeah I think that could be it I think
also that like Facebook lied to
everybody notice anything like that
video was was where we need to put our
money yeah and I think that like by
Facebook doing that they not only sunk
our democracy they also screwed up some
things because [ __ ] Facebook
unfortunately like I still have to
moderate the gastropod Facebook page
yeah I mean like I was off of it for
like a month or no for like three months
and I just now came back because I had
to sign into something and then
automatically signed you back and it's
just like well so I want to turn to
something else so that we can talk a
little bit and then I'll open it up just
because we started a little late but
there's a topic that I think is really
interesting that we both do in slightly
different ways and it's the role of our
own person in our podcast and so you
know you're you are you in our thing and
as you said on purpose like this is a
different space for you and I'm just
like the first episode you know where
you talk about your own stories and I
won't reveal the ending but there's a
really fun crush on a public radio
personality but but I know it's always a
deliberate choice so how how do you
decide how much to reveal like what
level of personhood and vulnerability to
reveal on the show yeah it just depends
it depends on like I in I believe that
like
tell great stories you have to be
vulnerable I think that especially if
you're telling stories about yourself
like if you're not willing to like be
vulnerable than why I do it like it's
boring so so that's always like the
number one thing that I'm thinking about
the the second thing that I'm thinking
about is like how do I tell that
vulnerability but also like kind of
protect myself as well and and so it's a
it's a balance that you just have to
like walk and think about I have like
some ID when we're planning out season
three there's a story that's like really
hard for me to tell and I thought like
no I think I'm ready to tell that story
and to give it justice and to really do
it but like you know that's the story
that I've been holding for years that I
haven't said anything that I that I
don't tell and so it's really about like
just being prepared for it but also like
at this point in my career so much of my
work has been autobiographical that I'm
kind of prepared for all the things that
can come from that and it took me a
while to get in that space where I told
a story on the moth once and I have a
daughter that passed away and I told a
story on the moth about it and um and I
I told that story strictly because I
always say my other kids names out loud
but I never say her name out loud and I
wanted to say Lauren's name in front of
an audience like she was here she
mattered but that was my only thought I
would didn't even let the moth pay me
for it
I just needed to do it for my own
purposes and when the moth plays it
people write to me about it in some
years when they write to me I'm totally
good with like responding in other years
they write to me and I can't I can't
even look at their emails and so it's
like this thing like that was a really
good learn a lesson for me to like
really take in like you are making like
these really private things public and
how you got to control that like you and
the only way you control that is
deciding when and when not to do it
and then and then knowing that once it's
out there for better force it's there
and then figuring out how to protect
yourself in that as well you know so
yeah I think that like it's just it's a
journey that you have to take inside of
yourself and figure it out but also like
what I'm really I the thing that I know
is I don't just tell stories cuz I like
to hear myself talk I tell stories
because I believe that storytelling is
is probably the most powerful force in
the universe if you think about it
everything that we all know about
anything we all learned from a story if
you think about everything that has
happened in our country politically it's
happened from a story I mean we went to
war over this story that there was
weapons of mass destruction that weren't
there you know
Germany put it created the Holocaust
because there was a story that these
people were less than America
you know profited 300 years off of Human
Bondage because they made the story that
like Africans were less than like they
were all stories and those stories like
had these really deep foundations and
they've created every single one of us
where we are and our own personal story
defines who we are defines what we think
about ourselves you know defines like
when we feel good about ourselves like
it's a story that we feel good about we
when we feel bad about ourselves it's a
story that we feel bad about it's all of
those things and so me recognizing it's
always in the front of my head that
storytelling is the most powerful force
in the universe and if if if it is that
then I want to harness that and use it
to do some good and so when I'm thinking
about like how I'm trying to make the
world a better place and I'm doing it
through story if the best way I can do
that is through my vulnerability then
I'm gonna use that and so those are the
kind of those are the ways that I look
at it and and
it's it's sort of like how I decide what
what I should do what I shouldn't do you
know the thing I tell friends of mine
all the time is that like I can't speak
for anybody else's life but I can tell
you that like my life is full of magic
like magic [ __ ] happens like I mean I
won a contest and I got my own NPR show
like no when I got my first NPR show
every like literally 200 people in the
NPR building wanted to stab me it's like
they've been working in that industry
for years and didn't get that
opportunity right I got another really
big thing that happened to me that I
can't talk about because NDA's or
whatever but literally somebody emailed
me and said hey want to do something
crazy like a TV show and I was like sure
you know like magic right but magic has
a cost you know like they're like you
don't get to like do magic and not pay
for it everything has a cost and so so
the hard stuff the vulnerability is that
cost but but out of that cost is where
the magic Springs out of it so I'm
thinking about all of those things in
how I engage with storytelling and what
I'm willing to give and what what I'm
holding for myself so that was super
beautiful and profound and I'm now gonna
follow it with something a little more
prosaic but which is you know gastropod
is a journalism storytelling show right
like we do stories about the science and
history of food and you know it's
everything from where does the idea of
school lunch come from and who does it
benefit and should they all be free and
what's the science of like you know at
school lunch - why do American mangoes
suck and how can we get them to be
better - you know who was the first
African American master distiller who
actually kind of helped create the brand
Jack Daniels the former slave so it's
kind of the history stuff and then also
science I'm in the middle some of you
know this year I'm in the middle of
doing this horrible personalized
nutrition study for gastropod it's two
weeks of torturing myself about food all
for my art it's really not
fun but I promise you it's gonna make a
really good episode because we're gonna
be able to talk about how nutrition
science is done but you see but it's
only two weeks I have another week to go
I can't believe I'm still doing this
so but but the idea of us as characters
as the host of this show was really
important to me from the very beginning
and when Nikki and I started talking
about it you know again she had no
experience in audio but I said the only
reason that people are gonna want to
come back every two weeks to spend time
with us is us yeah absolutely they have
to feel connected to us and not just
what I didn't want even just to trust us
as like the voice of authority I didn't
want that I wanted people to really feel
connected to us to trust us to trust
that we're gonna hold their hand and
take them through something super cool
really fascinating but that also we had
to occasionally reveal things about
ourselves now that to me doesn't mean
sitting around and talking for 10
minutes before the show about what we
had for breakfast nobody cares I don't
care I don't like it when people do that
on podcasts I find it boring but but we
drop in things about ourselves right
like there's you know if you listen to
the show we did an episode of a episode
about cilantro you'll know I hate
cilantro because we tried to train me to
like it we you know the fact that I'm
Jewish it's totally disgusting yes
you're like me you can't convert us
sorry it's really it's like in cilantro
like why do we have parsley Wow
like what like parsley in tabbouleh is
really good it's like it's okay okay so
like I would agree with you and that one
dish the rest
I've lived in Israel for years that can
be a good I agree talk about food
forever but um but there are things you
know my family my aunt got really mad at
me actually because we did an episode on
American Chinese food and Jewish history
New York is very closely intertwined
with American Chinese food and I talked
about how my great-grandparents were
legit communists because they thought
communism was better than the czars
right they had been killing us communism
like a better idea um and and it was
totally related to the story and my aunt
was horrified that I just like how could
you share that I'm like it's not a
secret those people are dead too and
like we're not dealing with McCarthy
anymore were okay but you know my
partner Tim comes on the show I make him
do things like I stick the mic in his
face before he's had his caffeine in the
morning for an episode on caffeine I
make him super bitter bitter melon to
make him eat it for our episode on
bitter he still loves me it's okay but
so these things I think that that these
personal bits you know what people come
up to us and they genuinely tell us like
I can tell they feel like we're their
friends absolutely and I I want to be
careful about that right because
sometimes they really think that you're
their friends but but that feeling of
connection is really important to us
these are people who are gonna tell
their friends about us we have people
who listen to our shows multiple times
which is kind of strange to me but
lovely and you know send us gifts and
come to see us at live shows and take
selfies with us and and give us
financial donations and all these things
and so to me that connection with the
audience and that little bit of
personality is still really important
even though it's not personal
storytelling like yourself absolutely
and I mean like I do the same thing on
reveal with reveal I am constantly
thinking about the persona of Al that
people are hearing and what I want the
persona vow to be and what what I really
want to be is I don't like because we
are doing hard news the last thing I
want to do is be like anybody on cable
news
anybody on on broadcast news and anybody
on NPR like I want to be like my own
separate little thing and that may mean
that some people won't really like that
version of what I do which I think like
that's fine because like you only have
to deal with me for a couple minutes and
the story comes on but then for a huge
group of people that I think love the
show like you know like I just want
people to feel like like I'm their cool
friend that we can have a coffee with
and I'm telling them something and I
also listen to him you know but I don't
want to sound like a newsman and so like
to not sound like a newsman
like you have to drop bits of yourself
here and there
and I also think that like when you are
very careful about what you give about
yourself in an episode or in a season
when you do when you do give your
humanity there like it has such a a
punch I'll never forget like Melissa
block who I loved on All Things
Considered pretty much like everybody
that's been on All Things Considered
like some of my favorite broadcasters
I'd love to listen to those people I'd
loved Robert Siegel and he retired I
literally like webbed toes like yeah I
am such a nerd but Melissa block was
reporting in China just on a trip and
then the earthquake happened and she
went and she was recording these people
they were excavating this rubble and
trying to get this kid out and his
family couldn't find their kid and they
were crying and then she got choked up
and you could hear her fighting it and
oh god it like I sat in my car and wept
like I just it got me so and then when I
saw I met her for the first time like
but I get was totally like that moment
of like you know like it is like the
most it is such an intimate art form
that like I am sitting in my car at
wherever I was going in park just
listening and weeping and I felt like I
had this moment with Melissa she
recently followed me on Twitter and
literally I like screenshot when I'm
teaching is that audio is the most
intimate medium you're absolutely ears
you're in their bedrooms you're going
with them as on a run you're hanging out
with them as they cook you are and when
you use the word you they feel like
you're talking to right absolutely
because you are you are you are because
I ever every time that I am like doing
any kind of recording I'm always
thinking about that one person that's
listening to me I'm not thinking about a
whole lot of people I'm if I
like thought about how many listeners
reveal has every time that I did it I
think it would freak me out so instead I
think about the one listener that reveal
has the one person that I'm just trying
to tell the story to and whoever's
listening to it is that one person yeah
so I could keep asking lots of questions
but we do have time for audience
questions if you guys have them yeah so
so the question if we need to do it
again for the recording was that you
know there's these kind of big shifts in
podcasting and Spotify but gimlet for a
huge sum of money as we all looked on
jealously and gimlet as a podcasting
company for I imagine that this audience
knows that so there's a lot of questions
about that right I mean and I've read
people like thought pieces about it I
talked to my friends in podcasting
obviously Nicki and I talk about this
all the time one of the worries we have
is as I said we're kind of a unicorn
right like we're a fine relatively
financially stable I'm never sure year
to year but independent journalistic
highly produced podcast that takes us
crap-ton of time most shows at our level
of research and production have seven to
ten people on staff we have two but
we're still independent and the we do
have our first intern so that's very
exciting but so the you know the
question is can will we still be able to
go it alone with
this kind of big money trying to
centralize things we don't know and
we're worried about that the other
question people have and this is kind of
what you're getting at is will things go
behind pay wall and that's a big
question we were in talks with a company
that wanted to give us money to come on
and put us behind to pay well but they
expected a very small conversion of our
listeners and we weren't willing to give
up our listeners and we just weren't
willing to do that yet that might end up
happening I hope not
because one of the great things is that
you know anybody can listen to it that
said the fact that it's free and anyone
can listen to it makes it challenging to
sustain you know NPR has its own model
it's it's its own model right and that's
not what we're all doing so I think the
answer is that nobody knows and
everyone's kind of asking the same
questions you're asking what does this
mean what's gonna happen what are we
gonna be able to listen to where's the
money going is it all gonna be networks
is it gonna be behind paywalls is it you
know who's gonna be determining what get
what like what types of things get made
oh that type of access not access to the
show well so I actually think so Spotify
just put out a show that I thought was
really fascinating it just came out in
February that is called dope labs dope
labs dope lab it's two young
african-american women doing a show
about science it's great it's fun
they're you know two buds who've known
each other for a while they are you know
they have some producers working with
them but this was their pitch and that
was Spotify you know you can find it on
any it's called like Spotify shows or
something but Spotify and Google I think
are all I think everybody's concerned
about the diversity of voices in
podcasting I mean this was part of this
has been an issue in public radio itself
for a long time and certainly is still
an issue today podcasting started out as
like kind of people in the know techie
know things there was two dudes talking
white dudes talking right like that's
what it all was so even women in
podcasting is still smaller and
certainly if you're going to non you
know people who aren't white then that's
like it's a whole other thing so I mean
I think clearly Spotify is trying to
address that what it means I don't know
what do you think
I worry about all of it I don't know I
don't but I I think that the jury is out
and we'll see I think that the thing
that scares me in America is that like
you know big bank is constantly taking
little bank and then big bank becomes
too big to fail and then we all get
caught up paying for Big Ben and
everybody fails right and then and then
the the people fail but big bank seems
to keep making money so I am generally
I'm it's a weird mix right because like
I know Alex he's we're friendly we
worked on things together before gimlet
and I'm super excited for Alex like I am
I'm personally like he's such a good
dude and his wife is Nazneen is like
freaking amazing I'm so fed Alex but
I've only met his wife on the show yeah
so it's like yeah and she's she's great
she's great so like for them personally
like I'm super happy for them like this
was his dream for the industry I'm a
little bit like you know we'll see you
know and also like I just think that
like you know journalism is just at this
bad place right now you know when you
think about like figuring out revenue
streams when you look at like newspapers
across the country that are being
decimated when you look at like what was
that what happened at BuzzFeed like
BuzzFeed but had like a ridiculously
talented young group of reporters if
they'd just gone and so it all scares me
and so I don't I I can't really give you
any hope other than like I'm I'm hoping
but I have no no no no solid thoughts
about what it's all going to land yeah
too soon too soon I think that like you
know the thing is with the with
diversity like what's interesting about
the idea about diversity now is that
like in a lot of ways we can now shame
companies in a way that we couldn't
before and bring and and make them pay
attention to things that they didn't
care about before some companies will
never listen but some
I think a good majority of them will pay
attention and so there's that there is
the there there is now the opportunity
for people to like speak up and be heard
and can make change so I'm hopeful for
that but we'll see other questions Tom
that was Seth I think they can be
slightly different things but I think
they can be the same thing as well I
think if you listen to like you can find
pretty much a podcast about anything and
these are things that maybe wouldn't
necessarily be paid I'll play it on
terrestrial radio stations but then also
like a lot of podcasts are being played
on the radio as well so for me like I
interchange the terms left and right and
then also like I definitely think of
reveal as both a radio and a podcast I
think of earthing as a podcast although
we have been played on the radio like my
primary thing is like with earthing like
I don't bleep out [ __ ] like I say it if
we did it on reveal we bleep it out you
know it sounds kind of funny I do - I
like I don't I don't believe in bad
language I believe in inappropriate
places to use Elaine would you but I
don't
so like for me like the I tell my kids
is - and it's like totally inappropriate
to use that language in front of me but
no I yeah so like for me like it's you
know those terms kind of just go
depending on what we're talking about
but I could I could talk about something
like it's radio and it could be a
podcast - you know but I think there's
space for doing things a little
differently you don't have to Hugh - the
Public Radio Hour absolutely there's so
many public radio shows that would be
better with just podcasts if they didn't
have to feed the beast yeah but I can
tell you from a news organization that
has to put out an hour every week we got
to feed the beast I think that like the
strength of reveal is that we
collaborate with so many different
people that we usually have a lot of
strong hitters but sometimes man we put
out our like and our show and the same
thing with everything but like our show
one episode could be could be 50 minutes
and we have a you know we come out every
two weeks like we're saying we you know
when you're gonna find us but it doesn't
but we you know and they can be
different tones they can be different
topics we're not you know there's no
expectation so I think that but I want
to kind of flip that around a little bit
which i think is something you'll
appreciate and it's that you know this
question of like is podcasting doing
something new you know when cereal came
out everyone was like this is breaking
the mold and I was like I'm sorry
nothing against cereal I'm not about to
but like I was like okay this is
serialized storytelling about crime this
is the art like radio early days of
radio people would lie under their
radios and listen to serialized
storytelling about crime you know like
so it happens to be a podcast spun out
of this American Life had done in a
different way but it's like it's not new
right it's although it's a remix it's
like it's it's like it's no it's it's
great and they did an amazing job
absolutely an amazing job with it but
yeah absolutely it uh it's it's not new
it's it's the context is new now but
it's not it's not new it's just new
forms about it ways to use audio yes
[Music]
yeah I I think one of my greatest
strengths is probably that like I
recognize that I need people and I am
I'm in this area I think in other areas
maybe not so much but in this area I'm
really good at putting my ego aside and
saying I need your help and so I went
around and I in the contest we are last
thing that we had to do our last
challenge was that we had to make the
pilot for state of the reunion and they
gave us an old not an old sorry talkie
they gave us a radio hand somebody that
done radio for a while not an old person
and I remain ever forget like I had like
five different people to choose from and
I at that point had knew a few people in
radio and I showed them like the list
and they told me like you should choose
talkie tell Anita's cuz he'll tell you
no and you need somebody that'll tell
you know and they were 100% right like I
chose talkie we worked on the pilot
together it was I'm sure I drove him
crazy because I didn't know what the
hell I was doing I was in the I was in
the field by myself I I didn't know
about room - I didn't know what the hell
I was doing I was just kind of winging
it and we put together we made this hour
that was actually fun and it worked and
I and in that process I really fell in
love with with what it was and so when
state of the reunion got greenlit the
first thing I did was I hired my best
friend to help me run the business side
of it I hired him because he's the most
honest person I've ever met and I knew I
could trust him he didn't know what the
hell he was doing either but we also
like
we were so tight at that point that like
I knew that we'd figure it out so I
hired him which was a great hire and
then I hired taki because talking new
radio and then I went out and I looked
for journalists that I you know opened
it up and let people apply and the
people that I decided to hire were the
people who showed a passion for the idea
and also like showed me some good
journalism chops and so they became the
core and they learned from me and I
learned from them I think that like
everything that I know about journalism
I learned from working with a really
great journalist but no I knew nothing
about journalism at all I knew nothing
about how public radio was made I think
that benefited us because we were doing
our first season we did some things that
you know we were just trying all sorts
of different stuff
and we tried it because I didn't know
any better and I'm so glad we tried it
because it may it made the show made me
better made us sound different but yeah
it was just a matter of like surrounding
myself with people who understood it you
know and people that I trust we need
more of it so Nicky my co-host didn't
I'm gonna answer that question with a
little story
so my co-host came from the world of
print and had never done audio before I
knew that she was a good public speaker
that our voices sound different that we
have a very similar sense of humor
apparently I grew up in DC but my
parents are from New York and apparently
like sarcastic New York Jew works really
well with British sarcasm so like the
two of us are kind of like the dry thing
works really well together but she
didn't know anything about it
and I taught her everything from the
ground up and she messed up with like
levels in room tone
stuff at the beginning man but so what
Nicky says is nobody told her that when
she started podcasting she wouldn't ever
be able to listen to podcasts again so I
when I listen to things I added them all
in my head I and then if I'm not editing
them then I think about what they're
doing and I think oh why did oh that was
a really lovely piece of writing oh that
was an interesting use Oh I wonder why
they chose to put that there so it's
really hard for me actually to listen to
things in the way most people listen to
them so I try to listen to things that
like it's not a podcast it's a public
radio show like I can hang out with
Peter sagal and all the other people
there all the time wait wait don't tell
me that's what I go running to cuz I
don't like there them and I've been
listening to that forever you know
there's a an interview show called nor
Det and it's you know they like nerd out
and their interviews young feminists
interviewing cool people and like I can
kind of listen to that and it's fun but
I'll find things and I'll listen and
I'll then from there I just kind of pick
and choose oh I want to listen to my
friend roses podcast flash forward or oh
you know there's this new thing Spotify
did called dope labs I'm gonna listen to
them oh that's pretty cool like that's
great that they're doing that I wonder
how that's gonna continue and where
they're gonna go with it you know I'll
dip in here and they're two different
peoples podcasts and projects and I have
you know I have a long list of things
that or it's something where I'm like oh
you know that would be a good fit for
gastropod oh I should listen to a bunch
of their stuff and see if maybe there's
opportunities to work together so that's
not a good answer
it's the answer is that it's like it
it's makes listening totally different
experience agreed I don't listen to
podcasts I don't even listen to my own
ten times while you're mixing it yeah
like people come up to me talking about
stories from revealing I'm like man that
intro idea took a lot of time no I mean
[Music]
so I I love podcasts but because I work
in it like I tend to like feel like I
just can't I
the in the next couple months I'm
actually like doing things like this
where I'm interviewing some pod some
people with podcast and so I'm gonna
have to spend some time listening to
those and I'm actually looking forward
to it because a good everybody says a
really great podcast and I just haven't
had time yeah I tend to like listen to
audiobooks I listen to a lot of
audiobooks like my audible cue is
ridiculous and that kind of satiates my
need for podcasting but I you know I dip
in every now and then I listen to the
daily occasionally a producer from
reveal who I absolutely loved left
reveal and went to the daily so I kind
of listened to support Ike because I
just love like so much
yeah yeah right it's kind of exactly so
I listen to that every now and then I
listened to a few podcast that they
tried to hire me and I said no just
because I want to see like thank God but
but but regularly no I don't really
listen to podcast podcast you know their
recommendations is probably like the
worst way to find other podcasts yeah
yeah I mean I think that like I haven't
okay you know what I did listen to in
the dark season to which I thought was a
revelation of a podcast the the work
that Madeline Britten Baron did and and
the people that were with her they just
they killed it and they did the thing I
think like you know I was just talking
about how we're doing a podcast has set
in the South a serial podcast and my
issue with a lot of both reporting and
podcasts when they go in and they tell
stories about the South they just kind
of parachute in
they get a lot of people saying y'all
and then they go out and then they're
like - all those are such interesting
right right then they spin whole like
did you hear they said yo did you see
what was on there what does it mean and
it just really irritates the [ __ ] out of
me like it really really makes me mad
but also like the idea if you have like
a great if you have a great story in a
community and then you leave with that
story and don't actually do anything to
help that community with that story then
I feel like we're just taking and not
giving back and I think that it's
something that journalism has done for a
really long time that journalism has
taken from communities all over the all
over the world and not given back
anything to it taking their stories and
and not giving people that are in those
communities understanding of what the
story means in the larger context and
how they can use that story to advocate
for themselves I think there's a
humbleness that really should go along
with reporting and communities that I
mean I've certainly been reporting in
communities that weren't my own but I
would hope that the final product does
something of benefit to the world and
certainly that I always feel like I'm
being a given a gift by their time yeah
and I think that's really important when
you are you know cuz you don't want to
as a reporter you don't want to just
stay necessarily in your own community
right but I think that you have to
really think that these are their
stories and their time and their lives
and a lot of them probably don't listen
to the media that you create right so
like if you're creating media about
these people and and sharing with the
world but they're you're hearing it's
secondhand like with s town I know that
like reporters just started showing up
who were reporting on that story and
like a lot of the people had no idea
what was in the podcast because they
they don't they're not tuned in the
podcast right what I loved about in the
dark season too is that they were very
active with that community and and they
figured out that the way that they the
best way to communicate with the
community was through Facebook and so
they have a very active Facebook forum
with
like many people like in the community
commenting on it like I just love like
the whole I love the holistic approach
of that journalism has a responsibility
not just to tell the truth but has a
responsibility to - for the people that
they are actually telling the story
about like we owe them something you
know they gave us something and we need
to give them something back so I can't
recommend that podcast enough cereal
season 3 I did not like season 2 but
cereal season 3 I haven't heard it yet
but I've heard really great things about
it yeah you didn't like it I think it's
just these are really talented
storytellers sure it's not my thing and
it's a little too slow for me yeah and
so I try I coast really loved season 3
and I tried and I was just like yeah it
just wasn't and I talk about this a lot
in general that there such a variety of
sounds and stories and ways of telling
stories and podcasts out there that
they're not meant you know obviously I
love everybody in the world to listen
gastropod but you know not everybody
likes every style
everybody likes every topic not and it
you know I genuinely am NOT a true-crime
person there are certainly stories about
crime that I find incredibly compelling
but it's not something that I'm gonna
search out and and there are some people
that that's like the only thing they
want to listen to great okay absolutely
yeah I don't I don't like true crime for
the sake of true crime I like true crime
when it's telling me something larger
where it's speaking to something bigger
totally there's a long answer yeah
first night class I asked everybody in
class by 18 students how many of them
were reading here a podcast listening 17
names when I asked them all right of you
guys what are the ones that you were
regular stuff and majority of them
didn't say narrative or storytelling
podcast there were things like the audio
equivalent of like a sports highlights
show it was recordings of stand-up
comedy sets entertainment news you know
things like that
and I realized that like you know I had
30 podcasts did I subscribe to my phone
every single one of them has some kind
of narrative structure of your shows so
did you guys keep those kinds of
audiences in mind or are they just
people that you yeah no I it's funny
only to this have you been to the
podcast No so there's a conference
called podcast movement and I had to go
when you're Howard on the conference's
in general I met you at a conference I
know it was the only time I went to that
conference and that's a good conference
but I'm just like I'd rather be in my
hotel room watching bad TV because I'm
an introvert but I went to podcast
movement and I was like blown away
at all the different podcasts there are
and how really small such a small little
section the narrative was that like
there's all this different stuff out
there so yeah I think about like how do
you bring those people in it's a
question that like we have been
wrestling with at reveal I can't talk
about the story but someone pitched a
story that was based in the basically
was a story that the Latino community
would be really interested in and we
started going down the road of figuring
out like how to do this like separate
podcast I'm really just it's I wouldn't
be the host of it like because I'm not
bilingual but one of the things that
came up from the
the people of Latino background in in
the office is that mostly the type of
narrative storytelling that we do does
not cross over so what we need to do is
we need to do like basically like a
talkie podcast that would be kind of a
separate podcast that talks about our
podcasts to get people our podcast or
separate pot so we would be doing like
two different podcasts about a podcast
podcast about a podcast podcast right
and then the podcast and that podcast
about the podcasts would all be
completely in Spanish because we are
trying to reach out to that audience
that normally would not listen to it but
this content is made for them it's just
made with the narrative structure that
maybe they're not used to so so we are
at reveal definitely thinking about that
I think when when I'm thinking about
earthing season3
so a lot of african-american podcasts
are the same way they're talkies they're
not they don't have the narrative
structure and so I'm thinking about how
do I cross over into the
african-american community that doesn't
listen to it and one of the ways that
I've been thinking about doing that is
being a host like I'm friendly with a
lot of hosts of those talky shows so
being a host of one of those shows doing
a segment with with I have this idea
who knows if this will be in season
three but there's a podcast host that is
really adamantly like against the NFL
for a bunch of different reasons and I'm
not really a big NFL fan at this point
either I used to be huge NFL fan but
when the concussion stuff started coming
out I felt really uncomfortable
and so my idea is for me and him to sit
down with two other African American
hosts who host like sports things and
for them to try to win us over but the
way we're gonna try to win each other
over is with stories of like why we love
football so I'm gonna get these guys to
think about narrative and then hopefully
I cross over on all of their podcasts
and I get what I want out of it you know
so love that I want I'm gonna hire you
to like help us figure out yeah yeah
that's that's like that's an idea so I
do think about those people yeah so I I
mean so I want to I think there's some
interesting points in there which is
even kind of what's the what is
narrative right so we run up against
that in gastropod where we were in talks
with a network and they were like we
love what you do like one of the bigwigs
there had tweeted we love gastropod we
should be doing what gastropod is maybe
we should bring gastropod in and we were
like okay look we'll talk to you to be
unnamed and and then when we talk to
them they're like okay yeah we really
like what you're doing but why couldn't
you make it like twenty five minutes
instead of forty-five come out once a
week and only tell a single story a
single narrative where like that
traditional idea of a narrative one
person does one thing and something
changes right and and we're like but
that's not what gastropod is like we
create these narrative structures around
a thing or a idea or sometimes the
person but rarely want like one person
usually is a mini narrative within the
structure of the show so actually
sometimes I feel like we have to argue
with people about what even is narrative
structure right like that I think that
gastropod has a narrative structure but
that other people think that it doesn't
fit I think that there's this obsession
with the word narrative and what it
means and that it only means the
storytelling whereas I think it can
apply to other things as well
obviously then we're not like a talkie
show right like if you just listen to
Nicky and me shooting the [ __ ] for an
hour I don't know we think we're kind of
funny but really we couldn't possibly
cram all the like cool information and
stories and science and history and
stuff we want to cram in without being
very deliberate about what we're doing
do I think about all of them yeah I mean
I won I think that different people are
looking for different things when they
listen to I think it's just kind of
breaking out of your bubble and trying
new things do I think I'm necessarily
gonna win all of them over I'm not sure
maybe it would take a while maybe they'd
need to listen to a few episodes
I'm not frankly I think the biggest
thing for me is I don't know how to
reach them I would be happy to I'd be
happy to be like and it would be kind of
a thing like you listen to all this
stuff try
these in the same way that I think that
the people who only listen to a very
specific type of narrative structure
should try listening to other things as
a way of kind of breaking out of that
idea of like what is the way that a
story progresses you know so yeah I
think about it I don't know questions is
weird sound and you've talked around but
you haven't talked directly about both
the process put some flesh on the bones
it's so much work to do this sure yeah
actually that was on my list of like I
had this list of like you want to know
what it takes here's a list of
everything we do yeah um so for me like
what I'm working in when I'm working at
everything on earthing what I'm
primarily thinking about is like I don't
want to lose you as a listener so like I
need to think every step of the way like
how I can keep you involved in it and so
that comes all the way the storytelling
in the sound design as well and so when
I like lay out a story I think about
like I think about it like I imagine the
way a musician thinks about composing
right like you know you do this for
eight measures but now you got to do
something to keep their ears hooked and
you do something else and you and you
and I love the build I love to like you
know start people off on this thing
where I'm like here and then the story
goes up story goes up story goes up and
boom explodes and then like the
descending action and then the story
goes up the story goes out boom explodes
and so I'm thinking about that the whole
way and so I'm thinking about that in
the storytelling a lot of times when I
do her thing and I'm telling my story
it's just me and the stew
I have my computer open to the script I
have the mic in front of me
and I know what the script is and I say
it and then I'm looking and think I know
I'm gonna freestyle it and do it this
way and then I keep going back and going
back and going back until I find the
sound in my voice that feels exactly
right then I go through and I begin
scoring it and I think about like the
music that like swells I never want
music to lead I always want music to be
a really great bed behind it but then I
think about like also like the best
advice that I ever got in radio was from
Hillary Hillary Frank she does the
longest short short time and that was
like podcasting is the most visual
medium there is because yeah like people
like close their eyes and they build the
world around them and so if I'm want
people to build the world around them I
got to give them all the tools to do
that
so the very first episode of earthing is
called Big Brother Almighty and it's
about my brother who's a psychopath and
what I did was I it was a story that we
were kids you know and so I went out and
I recorded a bunch of little kids saying
like you know your mama wears combat
boots like that kind of thing then I
went out and I recorded like the sound
of this area just the sound and and
dropped it in quietly behind there then
I then I thought about like the music
score that would work just right and I
at one point my brother is there was
this big bully that would always mess
with us and my brother was going to he
was about to hit him with a brick
while they dude was facing me my brother
was coming up to hit him with a brick
and I was like killing myself trying to
figure out what music and I was like
jaws nope because it brings that like uh
like the audience has no idea what's
going on and then and then I reveal like
he's got a brick in his hand and he
bashed him in there and then like you
hear like all the kids go oh you know
like and every like little audio thing
that I built around it brings people in
but every single one of those things
took a lot of time like I went out and
got little kids saying it and I was like
oh these kids suck so then I went back
and and I did my own voice I was like
like that kind of stuff and then I would
speed it up so or change the pitch so it
didn't sound like me
and then I deepen the pitch so it didn't
sound like me I do I do weird accents
and change them that takes time and
you've got like suddenly you put it in
the right place you like yeah it is the
most geeky nerdy ass thing I do
besides click comic books and it's it's
amazing it's thrilling and so I I don't
use much music for two reasons one I
don't have the rights to do it and it's
just not something like from the
beginning we didn't really think about
that - it's not where my particular
audio skill set lies is I think I think
it's really beautiful in what you do I
think it's often overused and especially
in journalism shows where they like why
is there music when it's just somebody
talking about linguistics there's no
that music isn't doing anything to move
the story around I don't really care
about music under a linguistics
professor so - so we don't use much
music but the show is music so like the
beats between when so Nikki and I record
ourselves separately in our closets and
then I mix everything together and you
know I do all the technical stuff for
the show and the beat between when a
guest ends and one of us comes in how
much we're talking over ourselves just a
tiny bit to make it sound like we're in
the same space to give it that more of
that natural feel but the and when I
hear it and when I get it just right
I hear the rhythm of like the music and
then like that metronome almost in my
head and they're like okay where do I
want that person
to come in oh yeah that's the
split-second where I want that voice to
come in and we do use a lot of NAT sound
because will either be doing field
reporting so most of it ends up being
from field reporting and everything I
can layer from that and then it'll be
multiple you know sometimes well
different people talking and I'll pull
you know to tighten it I have the laughs
here and then the person ducked under
here when they actually were talking
here and and crafting those scenes but
then also will play with sound like we
were doing an episode on the ways that
plants can actually hear in a way insect
on them and respond to those sounds and
so scientists have made recordings of
the insects and this is you know it's
when I'm doing it it's theater right
like you know I'm not out there like
those are recorded sounds of the insects
we're talking about it the scientist is
talking about it you hear the sound of
the insect munching on the plant get
louder and louder and louder and louder
and then we used Night of the Living
Dead to talk about that kind of fear or
you know we were doing something about
the way sound and influences your
perceptions of freshness and crunchiness
and taste and so you know somebody
talked about a metronome and breaking
glass and all these things and I could
mix those in and it's I mean it's fun
but it takes a lot of time and even us
recording you know we you know the whole
process of the show is we choose a topic
we go out and do deep research on the
topic we figure out who's a bunch of
experts are we look and try to find
examples of them speaking either on BBC
NPR YouTube to see if like they're
halfway decent speakers sometimes we
have to interview them anyway because
they're the expert on the topic then we
want to make sure we don't just
interview a bunch of white guys so we
think about the diversity on the show of
our voices then we do the interviews we
prep for the interview sometimes read
multiple books we write up questions we
transcribe all the interviews we go
through the transcriptions I mean we
have like an online an app that we use
but then we clean it up we go through we
highlight the things we think we want we
write a script I pull the cuts we do a
read-through with the cuts to see if it
works we edit it I mix it we listen to
it we you know we record it under our
you know in our closets we do it twice
we want to make sure that just art we
hit our tones right then we say to each
other
oh wait that's not the right emphasis
emphasize that word instead we mix it we
listen to it that sounds really weird
and awkward I mix you know we do some
edits that was wrong we missed that you
know that messed up we mix it again I'm
out of breath just telling you all it
a lot it's a lot it's but but it's also
like if you love audio production it's
hugely rewarding I mean the second
season of earthing the first episode 808
CIN 3 heartbreaks it took me like a good
3 months before I could finish that
piece because I couldn't I just what it
wasn't right like I was like so close
but there's just something not landing
here and when I figured it out like Oh
God like I was running my kids were
looking at me like what is wrong with
you because like hey it finally worked
you know yes I think it's I mean Al's
work is much more personally vulnerable
overall than mine tends to be I come
from a more traditional journalistic
background I published a few personal
essays back in the day about dating
those are kind of embarrassing to have
out there a little bit
also because your thoughts on the topics
change and your thoughts on
relationships change and there are
things I wrote it's not like they're
very much a snapshot of who I was and
what I was thinking about at the time
and I don't feel like they're poorly
written or anything but it's like a
little weird one was in The Boston Globe
magazine and one was on an online Jewish
magazine actually the editor of that was
like the one thing that came out of the
one time I went to third coast was I met
a print editor on an online Jewish
magazine and wrote a print story for her
so I do so those are kind of regret I
mean I think it's really interesting
because I think in traditional
journalism you're you don't use yourself
a lot in what you're writing and I think
and this was actually something we were
navigating when I worked for a World
Vision report we
some very old-school like literally a
guy came out of retirement to work on
the show and he was a news broadcaster
from Dallas who had interviewed a lot of
presidents and he's like you can't talk
about yourself you can't use the word I
and I'm like but this is this intimate
medium and people actually they hear
your voice it is literally you it's not
even just your voice on the page it is
like your voice so to not be present in
your piece is almost harder like it's
hard not to be a present in your piece
so for us I mean I don't regret any way
that we're we are ourselves in gastropod
and I think that we're very careful
about how we do it and it feels very
those moments of vulnerability on the
show as part of our journalism feel very
important to me yeah I am constantly
diving into that into the pool and I I
don't necessarily have regrets but I
think you know what you're saying is
that you know stories are always
snapshots of where you are and not where
you're going necessarily and so like you
tell a story like one day and it feels
like really true and the next day you
may be like that's not really that that
I didn't have all the information at the
time when I said X right so I have
stories out there like that where I'm
where I feel like mmm you know I was I
was trying to get at something and maybe
that felt right at the time but doesn't
really feel right now but I also feel
like I'm a human being and I'm gonna
grow and I just leave it like I've
podcasting the first season of our thing
that I've been tempted to take down
because I don't feel the same way I did
when I recorded it but now but but the
more I think about the more I'm just
like you know what just let it live like
it was a snapshot of where I was you
know but I do think you know like you
it's like I think vulnerability is
important but I think you know also like
protecting yourself is just as important
you know and holding on to you too to
your own stories as well that are
important to you I also think it's
important I know some of you out here
and right there are kind of early career
journalists and I think it's important
to think about what
what you're willing to have out there as
you're embarking on a journalism career
and people have access to I mean we we
talked about this a lot in terms of
what's on Facebook or what's on
Instagram or snapchat and theory
disappears but does it really you know
and and and how how much of yourself is
out there in the world and you know do
you really want is thinking about is the
stuff you want employers to be able to
see but I think even in terms of your
writing I think it's important to always
think about you know in an in my next
job application yeah it is something I
want out there absolutely and you know
like I am I'm coming from a place of
complete privilege in the fact that like
I am the host of a national show that is
doing really well I've hosted other
another show that did really well I've
got a bunch of you know shiny things
Awards or whatever that ultimately like
if if I leave reveal like I'll be able
to find a job and like the things that
I've written nobody's gonna hold against
me because there's a long track record
of what I've done
when you are coming from a different
position than where I am right now maybe
really different how you think about
like the things that you share
especially we live in this time when
like you know just let's be real like
the President of the United States
labels us as enemy of the P totally and
so like I get I get so many emails every
week about people calling us fake news
and being mad about the reporting and
all of that type of stuff so I know
there's a respond to it on Twitter oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah I respond to him
sometimes although although like I the
last one I responded to I wrote him
yesterday and I said you know what dude
like let's start this conversation over
again because I was really dismissive of
you cuz I was thinking cuz you're wrong
of course but we can have a civilized
conversation but anyway um so no I think
that like you have to think about all of
that type of stuff and it's just to be
really honest like it's a lot easier for
me to say that like I deal in
vulnerability because like ultimately
like I'm at a different space in life
you know
um I've got the accolades in the resume
where you know at this point in my
career like finding another gig or being
able to get funding to do my own thing
is is a strong possibility I couldn't
have done that same type of I couldn't
have been as vulnerable and open with
the type of stuff that I say this type
of stuff that I say now ten years ago
when I was first breaking into the
industry like no way I could have done
it no I mean like I've written stuff for
NPR that like I don't think is wrong at
all on their coats which blog blog
things that I totally stand by but I
think that you know if you write a
personal story about like how you've
been victimized by the police so I did
that like you know years ago or whatever
but like I can imagine like being a
young journalist trying to get in
somewhere and then someone reads that
piece well-written but also like
definitely has a point of view I can see
that being used against young
journalists so you have to think about
those type of things
also about how journalism and news
sources often can be extracted away they
go and so you know that making use of
course our public that something live
like one specifically can you do this in
Boston that reached out to teach
students at MIT the same we're tired
it's really we want to create something
ourselves and so those students went and
did a podcast with them over the summer
and it was very it then was finished and
produced and of course as you guys are
saying on podcasts it was not easy and
it was a the most beautifully the Polish
podcast but I bet the students in class
now I worked with the media background
that we're bringing in an audio person
we're going into this again and trying
to have this like participatory design
absolutely but I think that you have to
like if it's participatory I think that
you have to think you have to think
about clear roles right like re do you
love like cutting tape do you love like
doing all of that type of stuff like
getting in the weeds if you love doing
that then that's your part of the of the
show and they're bringing you content
and helping you put it together and
telling their story but I think it's
like literally you just need to decide
like who's gonna handle that side of it
to make it well-crafted and just dive in
but you like the thing is is that like
what you'll find is that maybe some of
the people you work with fall in love
with radio and they can do it you know
but maybe not maybe they just wanted
like you know there are plenty of hosts
in public radio who don't like cutting
tape there plenty of hosts who just like
come in sit down cut the mic on do their
thing
you know when it comes to reveal like I
I read background material on whoever
I'm interviewing a game plan with
producers I mean I'm all in in so many
different ways but I do not its I've cut
tape they're maybe four or five times
right that's not what I do
and so like if the people you're working
with if that's not what they do you need
to find someone that does that so that
way you can create something that's
really beautiful so you can have someone
tell you like that's not gonna work like
I think earlier I told you guys I said
that like I hired taki because taki
would tell me know the other side of
that is that taki would tell me no say
like that's not good audio but I see
what you're trying to do and what if we
do it this way cuz that'll make that'll
give you what you're trying to do but
it'll also make great audio right and so
you need somebody like that who can like
take people who don't work in this world
and explain to them how this world can
work but treat them with respect as in
like I see what you're trying to get at
so let's
get at it but do it this way yeah I
would say I mean I totally agree with
everything else at and I think that one
of the challenges with everybody can
make a podcast is everyone thinks like
I've literally heard somebody say like
everybody's voice should be heard and
like I'm not sure that every single
person's voice should be heard but maybe
there's a reason that particular
person's voice should be heard and the
the important thing to me is that if
somebody's going to embark on a project
they should be given the tools to do it
well because otherwise I think you're
kind of setting people up for failure
right like you're you're engaging with a
community is great but not if they're
gonna make a crappy product that
nobody's gonna want to listen to so is
it training for them is it you know
workshops at the beginning to to help
give them all the tools and then they
can sort of help figure out what they
actually enjoyed and maybe dig a little
bit deeper so that one person is like oh
I really like being on mic and one
person's like wow that was a really cool
hour-long session on editing we did or
wow that writing like I really took to
the writing and so I want a partner on
sort of more of that aspect of it and I
think if you don't help set people up
for success that way with people who are
really talented who have the experience
can help guide them then what you're
gonna end up with is where people feel
like they have buy-in but then don't
create something that anyone's gonna
listen to yeah so I know we basically do
we have time for one more I mean doesn't
seem like that if there aren't any more
questions we can wrap it up if there are
more we can take one more it's already
after 8:00 we good great let's uh let's
wrap it up thank you so much thank you
you